bonjour le lundi 4 juin lundi de
Pentecôte premier titre de l'actualité
c'est la disparition d'un des derniers
monstres sacrés du cinéma américain
Anthony Quinn il est mort hier à l'âge
de 86 ans 60 ans de carrière au théâtre
et au cinéma un géant à la gueule
inoubliable Viva Zapata Laurence
d'Arabie Casimodo Zorba le Grec Anthony
Quinn c'était vraiment une légende
Gérard
Almaz zB grec et sa vérité brute nous a
quitté Anthony quin force de nature une
des geules d'Hollywood a fini par lâcher
prise à la vie 1964 Zorba rôle fétiche
aurait été l'un des 20 films qu'il
retenait sur les 350 dans lesquels il a
joué depuis ses débuts en
1936 il y aura 20 m de satin blanc tout
couvert de perles avec le soleil sur une
mamelle et la pleine lune sur l'autre en
paillette
d'orpin 19
entre au firmament des grandes
[Musique]
ves face à la
bouleversanteett anthonyin incarne un
hercu pitoyable profondément
[Musique]
humain 1962 laenceab Dav l anonyin jou
un seigneur désert prof de poignard l'un
des meilleurs rôles de ce désespérado au
caractère
volcanique Anthony Quinn laisse C veuves
très orphelins sur le plan personnel sa
vie aura été également musclé voire
tumultueuse il pratiquait la fidélité
comme un
sport le parcours du géant du cinéma
aura été une suite de passion parti de
la misère de l'enfance mexicaine jusqu'à
la gloire hollywoodienne Anthony quin
avait voulu devenir architecte mais il
av content ans detit boulot avant queest
le propulse sur scène hen Verne le
connaissait bien il tourne beaucoup et
il est à la fois retiré parce que ces
moments les plus passionnants les
passionnés c'est sa sculpture et c'est
sa peinture des centaines de peintures
des dizaines de sculptures souvent des
bronzes dans lesquelles on lit une
admiration sans borne pour Picasso rôle
qu'Antony quin voulait à tout
interpréter un jour ou
l'autre il n'en a pas eu le temps
d'ailleurs c'est le temps qui me manque
le plus disait-il pour moi jouer c'est
vivre j'aime la vie alors je vis j'aime
jouer alors je joue mais jamais je ne
m'habituerai à jouer les
grands-pères